[Music]
janelle is in cleveland hi janelle
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave hi george can you hear me okay
absolutely what's up
um
my husband and i are 65
and our kids are 32 and 30.
and
i don't know when to tell them
how much money we have
now
now
um
well the only reason i'm hesitating is
because it's
1.5 million
yeah
so are they are they are they
misbehaving
oh no no
why do you why do you think this
knowledge will bring harm
um probably the way i grew up
i didn't know
anything about my parents finances until
i was
gosh probably
my dad died 55 maybe
i mean my parents just never talked
about it i never asked them right
um yeah lots of parents don't talk about
money or sex and then when their
children grow up they're surprised to
find out they had both
well they're both married and my
daughter is having a baby in about three
days so i think she knows about stuff
one down one to go i wasn't talking
about her sex i was talking about yours
but yeah i know
oh my gosh
yeah i i think you sit down now
you know when i had this conversation
with ours they were uh just coming out
of college
i didn't want them i wanted them to have
the maturity to be able to handle the
discussion the emotional and the
spiritual maturity
and uh we're a family of faith and so
the conversation started with this as
for me and my house we serve the lord
and so the information i'm getting ready
to explain to you is not
uh it is not you hitting the lottery
because you are not inheriting the money
you're inheriting the responsibility to
manage the money for god
and that's how we started the discussion
and that's still how we have the
discussion to this day they've yet to
inherit any money but
but they know they know what our wealth
is in detail and they know exactly
what's going to happen to every penny of
it uh we have a big meeting once a year
with our leadership team at our office
and with our kids and we go over the
real every piece of real estate we go
over
uh you know any of the wealth that is
there and exactly how the wheel remind
everybody how the wheels and the trusts
all work because it's kind of
complicated
and um you know we just have a review of
this and this is a transaction
so long ago they got past the emotions
of feeling like they hit the lottery
well i guess i'm wondering why why why
do i
what's the purpose in it because you can
teach them
to have the proper spiritual and
financial stance on this while you're
alive
otherwise you don't know what the
reaction is going to be and if you get a
negative reaction you may want to adjust
some of your inheritance
um
okay
because we i just yeah we don't leave
peop money to people in our family if
they're misbehaving because we don't
want to finance misbehavior with god's
money oh no no i wouldn't do that i know
but how about their
how about their son-in-laws or our
son-in-law same thing
listen if it's going to affect the if
the information that this money is there
is going to affect them how much more do
you think the money's going to actually
affect them
when it comes out of left field
and there's no time to emotionally
process it oh by the way we're also
processing the death of a loved one at
the same time
hmm
so the so you think the son-in-law
should be included in absolutely
they are at my house
because they may they're they're they're
family
they're not necessarily going to
actually personally get the money but
their spouse is
and so you dadgum right and you get to
speak to all of them
about what this means to you and and how
we you think they ought to view this and
that we're not going to allow you to
feel like you can put coke push the car
up into neutral because this is coming
you know we can have all kinds of good
discussions it's all kinds of teachable
moments